very heated debate in washington which
affects the finances of millions of
american families
it was there on capitol hill last night
that republicans unveiled plans for a
new stimulus package
to tackle the economic fallout of this
pandemic
their plan calls for a one trillion
dollar stimulus with a t
with the extra unemployment benefits cut
from six hundred
to two hundred dollars a week anthony
the democrats passed their
three trillion dollar plan in the house
in may
it would keep the 600 federal
unemployment bonus
paula reed is at the white house paula
that's a big gap between plans what's
the latest on negotiations
it's an enormous gap anthony good
morning well the showdown began
last night both sides agree on sending
another round of stimulus checks
approximately twelve hundred dollars
and they also agree on allocating about
a hundred or hundred billion dollars for
schools but other than that they're
about two trillion dollars apart
and a deal remains far from certain
the pandemic is not finished
the economic pain is not finished
senate republicans made an opening offer
to democrats last night
the heels act that's health
economic assistance liability protection
and schools the plan protects employers
from being sued over covid transmission
and extends some jobless benefits
like the 600 dollar weekly benefit that
is set to expire
but republicans want to reduce the
benefit to 70
to 75 percent of the wages a person made
before kovid we want to continue to help
the unemployed
but we want to encourage work the senate
minority leader chuck schumer blasted
the plan
the administration has bungled this
crisis and now they want to take sixteen
hundred dollars out of your pocket
every single month as coronavirus cases
continue to rise
across the country national security
adviser robert o'brien became the
highest ranking u.s official to test
positive
o'brien works in the west wing and
closely with the president
but as he left the white house monday to
head to north carolina
the president said he had not recently
seen his top advisor
no i haven't seen him lately i heard he
tested yeah
i have not seen him just as the virus
reaches his inner circle
the president while touring a biotech
company in the battleground
state of north carolina offered a vague
directive to some governors to reopen
their economies
a lot of the governors should be opening
up states that
they're not opening the trump
administration insisted that the
coronavirus bill include nearly two
billion dollars
for a new fbi headquarters building in
downtown washington
now that's unusual because it doesn't
appear to have anything to do
with covid and because the justice
department's inspector general is
investigating
whether the president tried to influence
that project to favor his hotel
which is about a block away anthony all
right paula reed thanks paula